روسيا كانت قد تصدت لهجوم بالمسيرات
الاوكرانيه بين ملف كييف ضلوعها بالهجوم
فما الذي حدث في المنطقه الروسيه المحاذيه
بالقرون
فقد اعلنت مجموعه من الروس المناهضين
للكرملين والمتحالفين مع الجيش الاوكراني
مسؤوليتهم عن الهجوم بعد ان سيطروا على
نقطه حدوديه بحسب شبكه سي ان ان الامريكيه
وفي الوقت الذي ادانا فيه المسؤولون الروس
الهجوم لاحظ المحللون ارتباكا واسعا نطاق
في الفضاء المعلوماتي الروسي حول كيفيه
تنفيذ الهجوم وكيف ينبغي لموسكو الرد
ومن غير المرجح بحسب محللين ان تؤدي
الهجمات هذه الى التحول في الزخم في الحرب
الاوسع في اوكرانيا التي تركزت بشكل كبير
في المناطق الشرقيه للبلاد
طبعت المزيد
لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا على يوتيوب
الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس
التنبيهات